the Middle East is a region of alliances
divided between two big military powers
the United States and Iran now the
United States has military bases across
the Middle East
and its allies include Israel Jordan
Saudi Arabia and many of the Gulf states
Iran for its part is allied with present
Assad's regime in Syria Hezbollah in
Lebanon the Houthi forces in Yemen and
elements of the Iraqi administration
Iraq also has strategic partnerships
with China and Russia and some limited
ties with Qatar and Oman four decades
ago Iraq invaded Iran half a million
people on both sides were killed and a
truce was eventually agreed in 1988 Iran
retook most of its lost territory the
war
triggered Iran's more expansive foreign
policy that we see today and its pursuit
of nuclear weapons and it built
reputations of some senior commanders
including Qasem Soleimani
in the 1990s and early 2000s the u.s.
fought two wars against Iraq and finally
captured Saddam Hussein in 2003
ever since US forces have been based
there on iran's border much to the
dislike of tehran in recent weeks iran
has conducted big joint naval exercises
with russia and china for the first time
in the gulf of oman and iran has
regularly and repeatedly used its proxy
forces in Yemen Syria and Iraq as well
as Lebanon to attack US interests and
their allies after the storming of the
US Embassy in Baghdad just a few days
ago President Trump had clearly had
enough for 20 years
major general Soleimani was the
architect of Iran's foreign policy in
the region Iran will not replace him and
his influence easily